c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
sont les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir patrick achi le premier
ministre ivoirien qui remet sa démission
et celle de son gouvernement à nouveau
cabinet est attendu dès la semaine
prochaine ce remaniement ministériel
était attendu
nous serons à abidjan dans ce journal le
mali ce nouveau de nouveau au coeur d'un
rapport d'une ong il s'agit cette fois
d'amnesty international 67 pages qui
reviennent sur l'impunité de crimes de
guerre et de violence commis dans le
centre du pays en 2018 nous serons en
direct avec samira daoud directrice
régionale d'amnesty international pour
l'afrique de l'ouest et afrique assez de
l'afrique centrale
le bilan des intempéries qui s'alourdit
en afrique du sud il y aurait au moins
trois cent six morts il s'agit à des
pires inondations que le pays a connues
et le bilan risque encore de s'alourdir
les vega matériels sont également
nombreux les détails à suivre
le premier ministre ivoirien patrick
achi a présenté ce mercredi sa démission
ainsi que celle de son gouvernement une
démission acceptée par le président
ouattara une nouvelle équipe sera nommé
dès la semaine prochaine pourquoi ce
remaniement les explications de notre
correspondant à abidjan a annoncé à
janis
cette démission du premier ministre et
de son gouvernement le président
l'envisager depuis plusieurs mois
d'après nos informations mais elle a
tout de même surpris certains
observateurs qui ne s'attendait pas à ce
que le remaniement ministériel dont on
parle tant depuis chez en 2021 ne se
concrétise maintenant à un an
d'élections locales et régionales dans
le pays alassane ouattara souhaite une
équipe exécutive plus restreinte plus
efficace de l'ordre d'une trentaine de
ministères au lieu des 41 qui existait
jusqu'à présent en conseil des ministres
le président a évoqué la conjoncture
économique actuelle a expliqué qu'il
était impératif je cite de réduire les
dépenses de l'état selon une source à la
primature patrick achi devrait être
reconduit dans ses fonctions mais pour
noël pour l'analyste politique sylvain
guay sans un autre scénario reste
envisageable selon lui d'autres
personnalités seraient pressentis pour
reprendre le poste de premier ministre
il se pourrait que patrick achi mérite
plutôt de celui de vice président un
poste vacant depuis la démission de
daniel kablan d'encan en 2020 quoi qu'il
en soit le nom du prochain premier
ministre et la composition de son équipe
seront officiellement dévoilés la
semaine prochaine j'ajoute que cette
annonce intervient à quelques jours d'un
discours très attendu du président
alassane ouattara devant le parlement à
yamoussoukro le 19 avril prochain un
discours sur l'état de la nation qui
s'annonce décisif pour la suite du
calendrier politique ivoirien
on en vient à ce rapport d'amnesty
international sur le mali un rapport de
64 par quatre pages qui pointe du doigt
une hausse des crimes de guerre et des
violences contre les civils en
particulier dans les régions du centre à
mopti et ségou depuis 2018 ce rapport
identifie également les différents
obstacles institutionnels et légaux qui
contribuent à cette impunité pour en
parler nous sommes avec samira daoud
directrice régionale d'amnesty
international pour l'afrique de l'ouest
et l'afrique centrale bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous ce rapport au fait t'es
pas d'effets de fait l'état des lieux
pardon des enquêtes concernant plusieurs
crimes commis au centre du mali depuis
2010 8 qu'est ce qu'il en ressort
car effectivement notre rapport dresse
un état des lieux de la réponse de la
justice malienne concernant les crimes
commis contre les civils en particulier
dans la région du centre au mali depuis
2018 et le constat que nous faisons
n'est pas très bon puisque malgré les
engagements répétés des autorités
maliennes et l'ouverture certes de
quelques enquêtes judiciaires les
enquêtes sont au point mort et les
victimes attendent toujours justice et
que par ailleurs se poursuivre comme
nous avons pu le voir ces dernières
semaines des attaques ciblant les civils
il faut rappeler que depuis 2018 ce
conflit aux mamies se caractérise de
plus en plus par la recrudescence et aux
exactions commises contre les
populations civiles que ce soit par les
courtes armé d'un côté qu'est ce qui
faut systématiquement des civils les
groupes d'autodéfense aussi qu'ils ont
commis des attaques délibérées contre
des villages et entraîné des véritables
massacres mais aussi des exactions
commises par des membres des forces
armées maliennes qui ont commis des
crimes et notamment des exécutions
extrajudiciaires donc en dépit de ses
engagements force est de constater que
le cours de la justice reste vraiment et
que les populations un plant de toujours
alors que justice soit faite alors
justement vous avez identifié de
nombreux dysfonctionnements et de manque
de moyens qui contribuent à cette
impunité notamment dans le
fonctionnement de la justice
la réfection notre apport identifier
différents obstacles à cette bonne
administration de la justice d'abord le
cadre légal qui n'est absolument pas
adéquat qui doit être harmonisé avec le
kdh avec le droit international elles
permettent notamment à des tribunaux
civils de juger ces crimes ce n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui c'est la justice
militaire qui exerce cette compétence là
laissé seulement à l'initiative du
ministre de la défense que des
poursuites peuvent être engagées devant
des tribunaux militaires concernant des
allégations tu vis des militaires et ça
c'est un obstacle majeur et en plus
d'être en contradiction avec avec les
directives des principes de la
commission africaine des droits de
l'homme il ya aussi l'accord de défense
entre le mali et la france de 2014 qui
donne aux tribunaux français la primauté
pour juger et d'éventuelles allégations
de crimes commis par des militaires
français en opérations au mali et à ce
jour aucune poursuite judiciaire n'a été
engagée notamment sur le bombardement
par l'armée française d'une cérémonie de
mariage à vos outils dans la région de
mopti
alors on peut on ne peut pas dire que
les autorités maliennes n'ai jamais
ouvert deux procédures judiciaires ou d'
enquête sur ces crimes mais vous le
dites dans votre rapport il ya d'autres
obstacles majeurs celui d'enquêté par
exemple dans des zones dangereuses ou
même celui de la protection des témoins
qui est crucial
absolument des enquêtes on est
effectivement été ouverte sur
d'importants massacres commis depuis
2018 par des groupes armés et des
groupes d'auto défense notamment le
massacre de colo qu'on peut louer ou
celui de dogo avouent qu'ils font
l'objet d'instructions mais celle ci
comme je le disais précédemment avance
peut par ailleurs il y en a d'autres
obstacles notamment le lan sécurité qui
limitent considérablement
l'accès aux enquêteurs et au juge les
sites ou les crimes sont commis le
personnel judiciaire est totalement
dépendant d'elle à plusieurs j stick de
l'armée malienne de la mieux se bat pour
pouvoir accéder à ces zones il ya aussi
la question de la protection des
victimes et des témoins puisque aucune
disposition mise en oeuvre pour
permettre à ces personnes qui pourtant
tout se trouvent dans des zones de
conflits parfois proche du personnalisme
ans suspecté d'avoir commis des
exactions et qui donc craignent de
témoigner du fait de possibles
représailles alors qu'est ce que vous
préconisez pour lutter contre cette
impunité aujourd'hui parce que nous
demandons c'est simplement de me
demander aux autorités de manière de
traduire en action leurs engagements en
prenant des mesures très concrètes avec
tant de reconnaître au pôle judiciaire
spécialisé sur le terrorisme cette
compétence pour enquêter sur les
bouteilles des crimes commis par des
militaires contre des civils et sans
autorisation du ministre de la défense
c'est garantir aussi la protection des
victimes et des témoins pour permettre
témoignages et d'élucider ces crimes et
aussi avec l'appui de leurs partenaires
demandé avec un malien de renforcer les
capacités économiques financières et
humaines du secteur judiciaire afin de
garantir que toutes les personnes
suspectées de crimes de droit
international soient poursuivis et jugés
dans le cadre de procédures équitables
la lutte contre l'impunité c'est ce
n'est pas un luxe même en temps de
conflit c'est absolument primordial non
seulement parce qu'il ya un devoir de
répondre aux victimes et à leurs
familles en matière de justice mais
aussi pour contribuer à la non
répétition de ce type de crimes contre
les civils que malheureusement nous
continuons d'observer comme nous avons
pu l'observer ces dernières semaines
merci beaucoup à samira daoud directrice
régionale d'amnesty international pour
l'afrique de l'ouest et l'afrique
centrale merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
cette nouvelle attaque terroriste au
niger ce mardi au moins sept soldats des
forces de sécurité nigériennes et ont
été tués et au moins 13 autres seraient
gravement blessé l'attaqué survenue dans
la région de tillabéri à la frontière
avec le burkina faso la correspondance à
niamey d'harold girard
le poste frontalier de paix tel collet
est situé dans l'une des zones les plus
à risque de la région de tillabéri la
taxe n'a pour l'instant pas encore été
revendiqué mais ce poste est
régulièrement la cible de ces attaques
depuis plusieurs années maintenant plus
largement la zone dans laquelle il se
situe la frontière entre le nord du
burkina faso et le sud ouest du niger
est souvent le théâtre d'attaqués
djihadistes de la part de groupes armés
qui veulent imposer leur libre
circulation entre les deux pays la
région de tillabéri elle est prise en
étau depuis près de huit ans entre les
violences du côté de cette frontière
burkinabè depuis 2015 et l'insurrection
djihadiste et de l'autre le conflit qui
dure depuis 2013 sur le sol malien ici
au niger le nombre de morts dus au
terrorisme a plus que doublé entre 2020
et 2021
direction l'afrique du sud le pays
connaît des inondations sans précédent
le bilan est très lourd au moins trois
cent six morts et il pourrait s'alourdir
des centaines de personnes restent
prises au piège par les eaux l'armée a
été mobilisée pour apporter un soutien
aérien pendant les évacuations les
dégâts matériels sont également nombreux
provoquée notamment par des glissements
de terrain axel ciment
il est venu en personne auprès des
familles endeuillées le président sud
africain cyril ramaphosa accompagné par
le premier ministre de la région a pu
constater l'ampleur des dégâts et la
dévastation il a promis l'aide du
gouvernement
cette banlieue de la ville côtière de
d'urban dans l'est du pays et l'une des
plus sinistrés par les inondations
meurtrières
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi des pluies
torrentielles se sont abattues sur la
région provoquant d'importants
glissements de terrain pose effondré
routes impraticables la boue accumulée
souvent déblayé par les habitants
eux-mêmes avec les moyens du bord
on a réclamé de l'aide mais personne
n'est venu alors nous les habitants on
fait ce qu'on peut
à d'autres endroits l'armée a été
mobilisée notamment pour apporter un
soutien aérien pendant les évacuations
le bilan est meurtrier et des milliers
de maisons ont été détruites
plusieurs centrales électriques ont
également été inondés provoquant
d'importantes coupures d'électricité
sachez également que les habitants du
township de bamba d'urban manifester
aujourd'hui contre des manquements des
services publics après des coupures
d'eau et d'électricité provoquée par les
inondations les manifestants bloquaient
bloqué la rue pour demander les
autorités de la ville de réparer les
infrastructures endommagées
le début des travaux des assises
nationales en guinée depuis quelques
jours les membres du comité de
l'organisation sillonne tout le pays
objectif recueillir les propositions des
guinéens sur le type de réparations au
crime que le pays a connu depuis son
indépendance ces assises voulue par le
chef de la junte le colonel mamadou
doumbouya sont perçus comme des journées
de pardon et de réconciliation entre les
guinéens
le représentant spécial de l'onu pour
l'afrique de l'ouest et du sahel mohamed
salah al adib était en visite mardi 12
avril à ouagadougou une visite pour
rencontrer le président paul henri
sandaogo
damiba pardon le diplomate a réaffirmé
la disponibilité des nations unies à
accompagner le burkina faso danse et la
transition écoutez
séchage que j'ai nous avons eu avec le
président de la transition
partent du principe que depuis qu il y a
eu le changement au burkina faso les
nations unies
avec les autres partenaires notamment la
cedeao ce sont mes dans un logique
d'accompagner la transition nous l'avons
remercier pour le fait que maintenant
désormais le pvda kaboré
libre ce qui était des exigences de la
cdo nous nous sommes félicités que le
procès qui n'était pas attendu à plus
prendre également fin et nous avons
réaffirmé notre disponibilité toujours
d'être à côté d'eux autorité de la
transition
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'agresser avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]